[MUSIC PLAYING]
Orbiting is an
installation piece that
is circled around a machine.
And the machine creates floating
objects with a very particular
material.
And these objects find a
particular choreography
in the space.
And the idea is also to create
a very unreal atmosphere
with that.
No one has ever done it,
to make the machine that
produce a floating object.
So that's, from the scientific
or engineering point of view,
it's really interesting.
So right now, we're still
looking for a new material
that is very low density.
We were trying everything we
could do in a very fun way.
So that's why I think we found
a material from a very daily
object like a glass or bubble.
It may take like
three years more.
But as long as we have this
final goal to be realized,
I think this process, every
step, is really meaningful.
Hiroshi Ishii is
a scientist that
has a very artistic
approach towards processes
of production,
processes of research.
He has a very good idea of
the aesthetical outcome of it.
And also in this work, with
the Tangible Media Group,
I think there is a clear
awareness that aesthetics
add some kind of
meaning to an object
or to a machine that goes
beyond the pure functionality.
Well, artistically, Thom
projects a lot of the meaning.
He wants to make
many object which
represent cultural symbols
floating in the air,
circulating, and then disappear.
Process is very ephemeral.
And usually, we have a final
artifacts, like objects.
Like scientific work, published
paper is a final product.
But all the process, struggle,
discussion, prototyping,
failing, laughing, and
crying, never be captured.
But that has a real essence
of the collaboration,
with joy, also value.
If you work with many people
who have different perspective,
you can really expand your
scope and the boundaries.
As an engineer and a scientist,
that really piqued my interest
because I feel
like in art you can
ask these sorts of questions
that aren't practical
and that maybe have no
immediate function or utility,
but ultimately push the
bounds of what we can think of
and what we can do.
If you want to make
stuff float, you
need a very, very thin,
pliable, elastic material
that you can kind of blow
up and maximize the surface
area to volume ratio.
Thom, for this orbiting project,
wanted to do the opposite.
He wanted a material
that was rigid,
that could be
molded into a shape.
And then right as it's molded
and inflated with helium,
could just float away off
of a fabrication machine.
And here, it was really
just a simple question-- can
you make stuff float that
takes on new geometries
and has new properties?
And what is the fabrication
technology you need to do that?
All the stuff
floating in the air,
it's something
very, very strongly
imprinted in our brain.
So even if the project
does not reach that point,
I hope we can keep dreaming
the which we can really
control the gravity
that make things
float in the air at our will.